[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan Lee ESPN college football NFL
analyst and works for Westwood one he's
busy the second overall pick by the
Chargers back in the 1998 draft and uh
also the CEO of ram consultant
Incorporated college and NFL analyst you
got a lot of things going on and uh your
podcast bust the Ryan Leaf story let me
start here because it feels like there's
a few that's been going on with you and
the former GM of the Colts bill polian
for a long long time
now how did it start and why are we
still talking about the 1998 draft well
it's the 25th anniversary so it's been a
quarter Century
um and so people were talking about it a
lot and uh he went on a podcast for the
33rd team uh it's a bunch of uh you know
former GMS and coaches and things like
that talk about what's going on in the
NFL and and uh you know
um relive the the draft story from from
25 years ago
and unfortunately there's been a story
that has been out there for a long long
time that when I was asked what I would
do after I was drafted my response to
the Colts at the time was that uh when
they when they asked when can you be in
the facility can you be in you know you
could be there a week afterwards and my
response apparently was uh I can't I
can't be there
um me and my boys have a trip to Vegas
for seven to ten days
is that true no I've I've never uh
spoken I had never spoken to Bill polian
I'd never spoken to Bruce Arians I'd
never spoken to uh uh Jim Moore Senior I
missed my meeting at the combine because
I'm an MRI it became a big deal and then
uh at my pro day I didn't speak with any
of them I just went out and bawled and
spent most of my time with the Chiefs
and the Chargers that day with June
Jones did you not want to go to the cult
I didn't care
but did you want to go to the Chargers
didn't care
either one for me was fine I wasn't
pushing for either Lee Steinberg in his
book pushed a narrative that we weren't
interested in going to Indianapolis but
I thought you told us years ago that you
sort of Tanked your interview with the
Colts or you failed on them that was Lee
that was Lee I had an MRI with the
Chicago Bears and uh so I missed the
meeting uh assumed that we would just do
it again the next morning and but Jim
Moore Senior uh threw a big fit uh in
the media and it was a big story and I
was just like what this is this is
absurd okay but is your agent
responsible for this yes or is Bill
polian no my agent is
uh I found out a few things over the
last week uh Bill pulling and I talked
this week after I got after him a little
bit oh he called you yeah okay yeah we
wanted to have a conversation uh
apologies yeah
yeah you know
um I think that uh my wife and I were in
the car we just dropped the kid off at
school when he called so she was with me
in the drive she loves to just type on
notes things I should say and she shows
it to me as I as I drive okay
um
but yeah I thought it was good adults
had a conversation I was you know I
think the biggest thing is I didn't
think I was worthwhile enough for the
longest time to have my own back I don't
maybe didn't think I I had a chance in
Houston at the Houston Super Bowl
um McLovin and I and his and our wives
were at uh lee Steinberg's party and I'm
at the urinal and up walks next to me is
Bruce Arians and I remember thinking in
my mind at the time I'm like
this perfect time to confront him of
course in the urinal yeah yeah I didn't
I didn't say anything I still it was
like I don't know two years three years
out of prison and I just still felt kind
of
still like a kind of a POS and so uh I
just didn't have the backbone to do it I
have a little more Resolve right now I
like who I see in the mirror so I just
on last week I just said I was fed up
with it I'm tired of the revisionist
history this could never have happened
never have happened we never met uh so I
let it let it be known and I think there
was a really good response from it and I
think it made me you know it made me
feel better about myself and finally
sticking up for myself yeah because it
does feel like that everybody in the
Colts War Room wanted to take Peyton
Manning and not you and that's not the
case no no that I was told that they had
it might have been split because you had
more Talent than Peyton you in my in my
opinion you had more ability than Peyton
he had more Mobility you didn't have the
approach that he had and that's what's
made him one of the great quarterbacks
of all time I I did have the approach I
watched film like crazy I loved practice
I did all the things
I just was unprepared for what how money
was going to change me you cannot
quantify you can't quantify that
variable at any point now I do think
that's changing with nil I think you're
going to start to get an understanding
from some of these guys when they make
millions of dollars while in college but
how did money change you the idea that
success was money power and Prestige I
don't know where I where that was taught
to me it wasn't for my father it wasn't
from where I grew up but it was that
that made me more important than you
and I didn't have to listen to anybody
so you didn't have to lower yourself to
a reporter asking you a question right I
was I was rich and famous and I played
football if you had gone to a different
franchise
any better no oh you will you were who
you were and money was going to change
you money and the other variable you
can't quantify and for me we couldn't
how was I going to deal with failure at
the very highest level
what if I would have led the league in
the interceptions my rookie year like
Peyton did how would I have dealt with
that probably horribly because I saw
that as failure yes so those were the
two things now if I went to Indianapolis
with Marshall Faulk and Marvin Harrison
may have my Character defects been let's
say not seen for a little while longer
but Geographic change for somebody like
me it doesn't matter no matter where I
go there I am and so if I'm the problem
I have to fix me before any of it can be
realized in a positive way so I don't I
don't like the revisionist history
around my talent uh my my Approach okay
um
I think the things that need to be
talked about was the idea that
um everything was going to be easy like
it like I thought it had been in college
and in high school which it wasn't I
worked my tail off but I just in my mind
thought I could just go out and do what
I did my whole life but I I always say
this and and this comes from a source
who's a scout who said I always want to
see the series after you through an
interception like that tells me more
about you than I'm going to stand back
there behind a great offensive line
great wide receivers and I'm just going
to throw touchdown passes I want to see
when you fail and you respond that that
tells him a lot about and he's he's
Scouting For AFC teams right now but
looking at this draft
like I'm not sure about Anthony
Richardson
Talent
but he wasn't Talent enough to dominate
in college
CJ Stroud it's hard to assess an Ohio
State quarterback and so the best wide
receivers they're bet they have right
they have a better wide receiving core
than a few NFL teams yes they do
um will Levis couldn't start at Penn
State
head and hookers 25 coming off ACL
I I mean how many quarterbacks should be
drafted in the first round not will be
but should be I only have two first
round grades on quarterbacks in this
class okay and that's Bryce young and CJ
Stroud I have a uh are they close I
think so yes I for the longest time saw
him as the first overall pick to
Carolina just because of his size
because of his accuracy is he falling
he is I think in the eyes of a lot of
the media I have a call I had a call
with uh um somebody pretty close to the
Carolina Panthers this last week and uh
you know the the S2 test you know
through uh through a wrench into the
nice clean session now this is for
quarterbacks yeah it's so the Wonderlic
was an all-encompassing test that was
taken by everybody for the longest time
at the Combine they've because of new
data and new ways to do different things
this was more of a
um reactive test in real time in real
time and uh scores got leaked last week
and CJ Stroud's score was not but
explain to me how this you know since
we'll never be in that room what it
what's it look like when you go into the
room to take this test it's almost like
a whack-a-mole you know you you it pops
up you hit it right so it's all visual
yes there you're you're standing there's
the red light there's boom your reaction
is peripheral okay so this is Red Light
Green Light type type of things and
reactionary two things stimuli when
something does this how do you react to
that safety drops down to the strong
side you wheel back and throw a backside
eight cut uh for the post things like
that
um San Diego had me do something very
similar it wasn't called the S2 at the
time when I went down there for uh
really kind of a cognitive
um reactionary drill and I killed it
like the peripheral for me was was
really good
um our Wonderlic Test Peyton and I were
identical so again it's all these things
um I don't know if I put a ton of stock
in it
he sure looked good reactionary well he
was at Ohio State yeah you know throwing
touchdowns uh and so I I like them a lot
I I think that he can be a good Pro
quarterback I I thought with him having
Frank Reich uh Josh mcnow and Jim
Caldwell in place I thought that was a
really good fit for him I think it will
be for Bryce young too I suspect both of
them will be the first two quarterbacks
the teams let's say the cult who would
leak this
because we know you know strategy
leading up to the draft and there's
there's stuff that comes out like will
Levis you know his side of things the
cold-sided thing like I don't I don't
discount anybody in a situation like
this like why did this get out why is it
getting out now and who's it benefit
well I think there could have been some
blowback from Carolina folks if they
were if they didn't take CJ Stroud I
really do and so this may be a way for
them to
you know oh they're validating their
pick by saying this is why we didn't
take CJ yeah
okay I do think that has something to do
with it and I also think there was some
of that involved with what uh the cold
strategy was for me I I think a lot of
people may have been upset if they
didn't draft me first overall well hey
here's all the stories we got for you
you know this is this is why we didn't
do it and there was never really a uh
you know a a chance I think Jim irsay
really
um
you know I think he he really wanted me
and would probably understand why we're
both very impulsive individuals uh and
so that makes a little more sense 25
years later and him and I've had a
conversation about it I asked him the
question I was hosting Rich Eisen show
one time and I had Jim on and I asked
him the question how like how close was
I to be an occult and he was uh he said
I talked to a a guy that I trusted them
immensely in the NFL who'd been in the
NFL for a long time and he flat out told
me you you can't pass on this Leaf kid
and I said well good thing yeah good
thing you didn't listen to him
so I do think there's I think there's
something to that I think there's
leverage I think there's understanding
about winning the pr battle I do think
now that uh I put my mock out a week ago
when I had CJ Stroud as the number one
overall pick uh and then Houston making
a couple moves to try to get the second
and third pick I think that changes now
of course
um I do think Bryce young goes number
one overall yeah I Anthony Richardson
once again uh got a lot of ability will
Levis looks like a guy who's going to
play a quarterback in a movie
hand and hooker I like a lot but he's 25
coming off ACL I got I'm just trying to
figure this out that you know Bryce
young you know he's small I just want to
know if you can play I think and I think
that the the two guys at the top have
showed that they can play and I think
hand and hooker is shown he can play
Four interceptions in the last two years
guy is accurate some people have
questions because of what Josh heipel's
offense is like in terms of how it
translates to the next level I had
somebody who said that hype will put him
in a position to succeed well I would
hope so I I know but but that was you
know once again you got like Baker
Mayfield when he's in Oklahoma hey
Lincoln Riley put him in a position to
succeed what does that even mean
wouldn't you do that as a head coach no
but then then can he succeed on his own
when he doesn't have Lincoln Riley or
when you don't have Josh heipel when you
go into the NFL and let's say you have a
head coach who's defensive minded not
offensive ended so I mean there's so
many variables that go into a successful
NFL quarterback the White Spot the right
coach the right Personnel how do you
deal with failure all these things and I
do not think that the organization's
actually take as much accountability as
they should when they label a guy a bus
let's say Anthony Richardson goes to the
Colts and they want to hold him they
wanna
keep them on the bench let them learn
but Gardner minshu struggles the town
starts clamoring for him to come in he
comes in pulls on the leak Willis
doesn't look like he's prepared ready to
go all of a sudden that disappears and
now because of the rookie salary cap
Indianapolis is back in the market a
year from now looking at Caleb Williams
or Michael penex Jr or Drake May and
everybody's just like
you know Anthony Richards in the bust
well guess what Anthony Richardson
probably shouldn't be drafted in the
first round in fact I have a third round
grade on him so if that's the case
you're doing this you're doing him a
disservice unless you have a plan ready
for him and I don't know if anybody else
out there at all is advocating for
something like this maybe it's because I
went through what I went through but I
don't want to see anybody else fail I
don't want to see them well he could go
to Seattle and sit for two years you you
think
well because you better have a plan in
place it better be executed Rock Solid
when you draft them if you're
wishy-washy with it then that's on you
yeah Caleb Williams if he came out this
year would be the number one overall
draft pick and I do think Michael penex
Jr would be the number two overall pick
the Washington quarterback who
transferred from India I really think he
has a chance to be the best Pac-12
quarterback next year and be the Heisman
Trophy winner if he has the season he
had last led the nation in passing he's
got his receivers back well this is
going to be an unbelievable Pac-12
season in terms of quarterback play I
mean you have Bo Nicks you have dju at
Oregon State under Jonathan Smith you
have Caleb Williams you have Cam Rising
when he comes back
um Michael penex Jr the Pac-12 is is
loaded what we saw this year from the
SEC in terms of quarterbacks for next
year's draft we're going to see it in
the Pac-12 next year you know who I love
and he's not going to get love
the UCLA quarterback
I got him a second round grade I really
like him but you know since I've moved
to Connecticut you and I are kind of on
the side I know and that's scary that's
scary
we have certain Tendencies but not other
Tendencies I like uh I like the way you
think there too tons of starts tons of
uh experience played in a pro style Chip
Kelly I know I I like he's got velocity
for a smaller guy he can move I mean if
you put him in a in an offense similar
to what we saw Shane steiken do a year
ago with Jalen hurts they remind me a
ton of you yes a lot of each other so I
don't think he'll go in the second round
I think you'll get a steal with him
maybe in the third early fourth and he
can end up in a place where ultimately
I'd love to see him in Baltimore
so would I if you didn't have Lamar and
you decided I mean maybe I'm overselling
I just I like what I saw and and uh I
hope he gets an opportunity and he's not
waiting on that Third Day Before I Let
You Go Bijan Robinson should be taken
where will be taken
uh with his talent he should be a top 10
pick easily but the running back
position is so devalued yeah but if I
make him Debo Samuel now he's different
I gotta make like if I'm a running back
I want to be going in as the hybrid I
want to be that kind of running back he
is but they still aren't willing to now
I will say this
being able to draft a player because of
the rookie salary cap and get a fifth
year option and most likely add a
franchise taken you may have them for
seven years on a limited amount of money
yeah if that's the way you're thinking
and you think it's a piece by all means
I haven't gone to the Dallas Cowboys
around 20 what 26 yeah
um he might go to the Falcons
yep he might go up early Arthur Smith
needs to do something I don't know what
he's got on Arthur Blank but I've never
seen a guy that's been so mediocre in
his first two years you know you know
just kind of kind of just sliding by
through everything he better win this
year it's got to be a conversation
around that he's Ryan Leaf always great
to see you you too you make us smarter
his uh Sirius XM radio show NFL ESPNU
Pac-12 radio and uh the podcast bus the
Ryan Leaf story and uh working the draft
college football NFL analyst Ryan Leaf
thank you buddy thank you for stopping
by we'll take a break phone calls coming
up after this